Before we move on to the next stage, which would be dispatch,
let's do a issue quiz. So in this quiz, we have our instruction queue,
we have our RAT, we have our register file, we have a reservation stations.
These two instructions are already reservation stations.
There are two left to issue. And these are the values of the register file,
of the RAT, etc. So your task is to issue these two instructions,
or at least issue those that can be issued at, at this time.
You don't need to consider when these instructions are going to finish,
just issue whatever can be issued in the next several cycles,
assuming that these are just not going to leave from here anytime soon